so liebe zuschauer und jetzt haben wir
mal ein paar vollpfosten auf einmal raus
hintereinander weg traditionell ein job
für ulrich von heesen und gernot
hassknecht sie stehen hier um die ecke
auf einem besonders trostlosen
weihnachtsmarkt und verkaufen glühwein
und wie läuft so jungs bloß auf welche
besoffen hier aus verzweiflung schon
unsere eigene platte weil kaum einer
kommt und ich hab noch farbverdünner
dazu damit ich blinkt werde und das
elend hier nicht mehr sehen muss unser
einziger kunde ist der polizist der den
impfstatus der besucher kontrolliert die
nicht kommen
noch ein
dafür haben wir aber zeit nebenbei die
ollen vollpfosten zu verpacken und er
kommt nie drauf an wer der erste geht an
die scheuer diesmal für sein lebenswerk
der schlimmste verkehrsminister des
planeten verabschiedet sich und verpasst
dabei die letzte gelegenheit für einen
hauch von selbstkritik wir haben viel
geschafft wir sind in der spitzengruppe
weltweit mehr als das autonomes fahren
wer hätte das gedacht der deutschland
takt der ist beschlossen haben wir schon
beschlossen das haben wir schon getan
beschlossen und unterschrieben
broschüren die dazu läuft also so
schlecht was dann doch nicht
unfassbar bis zum schluss an die scheuer
2021 endlich abgewählt andere wurden
gefeiert wie bild chefredakteur julian
reichelt gefährliches modell die
öffentlich-rechtlichen zb mit jan
böhmermann oder der heute show machen
offiziell satire eigentlich sind das
inzwischen natürlich wie wir hier sehen
politische propaganda sendung julian
reichelt dagegen macht offiziell die
journalismus will aber eigentlich
praktikantinnen kennenlernen und das
stimmt doch so gar nicht auch
volontärinnen
und dafür gibt diesen hoch verdienten
preis und der pfosten passt super zu
recht weil wir hatte so was falsches du
hast aber den falschen das ist dir hier
für reiche warum ist ja so klein
materialmangel weltweite lieferkette
lasst uns aber um himmels willen das
eigentliche thema nicht vergessen der
geist von julian reichelt lebt weiter
bei der welt stimmt neulich gab es diese
heads schlagzeile die lockdown macher
wollen und zweien achten ruinieren
wissenschaftler die einfach ihren job
machen am selben tag lassen sie scholz
baerbock und habeck mit der springer
prominenz bei einer gala fotografieren
heimlich geiles tagen und für diesen
beherzten auftritt bei ein herz für
kinder gibt's den ein gehirn für die
ampel posten wird offensichtlich
dringend gebraucht wo ist denn jetzt der
pfosten für max berg den kannst du gar
nicht finden er ist rein virtuell
von wegen hier ist er doch eine
whistleblowing hat neulich verraten wie
genau der facebook konzern bescheid war
es über die schäden die er anrichtet ob
für demokratien oder essgestörte
teenager
falsch das heißt gar nicht mehr facebook
das heißt jetzt meter zuckerberg hat
sich als sein eigener avatar ins
metaversum verzogen
ach so führe dann schick ich den pfosten
doch mal da hin
[Musik]
und dann gibt es natürlich noch einen
besonders schönen posten für unseren
lieben viktor orban auch in 2021 hat er
ungarn wieder ein stück undemokratische
junger neuerdings dürfen da zum beispiel
kinder und jugendliche nichts mehr über
homosexualität lernen was
heißt dass ernie und bert müssen sich
trennen leider klar um ganz kinder
sollen gar nicht mehr erfahren dass es
homo oder transsexualität überhaupt gibt
sehr merkwürdig aber bei der ganzen
sache geht es wohl vor allem um den sohn
von orbáns außenminister
es dürfe nicht sein dass sein sohn eines
tages nach hause kommen und von einer
sexuellen propaganda beeinflusst sich
geschlechtlich neu orientieren wollen
euch so außenminister peter sie hatte
das ist ja furchtbar dh dem ungarischen
werk unterricht gibt auch nicht mehr den
kurs wir basteln uns einem u leider nein
hier mein lieber viktor das ist dein
transphobie pfosten kannst du dir
wohin tun hat mal hier der typ das ist
der größte versorger
2021 ich habe vor einem halben jahr eine
playstation fünf mal ihre stellt bleibst
du hast bleibt stehen du sollst stehen
bleiben
gernot das noch nicht der echte
arbeitslose sie verkleidet das kann sein
aber vielleicht katana bricht denkt
höher nämlich sein geld weg und die uhr
ulrich von heesen und gernot hassknecht
vielen dank so und das war es fast von
uns am ende eines jahres in dem unsere
deutsche gesellschaft angeblich so
gespalten ist wie lange nicht aber meine
damen und herren selbst wenn das stimmt
es muss ja nicht so bleiben meint
friedemann weise schlimmer noch er singt
es
die eine kriegt in mitte neues vantage
parkett der andere hat in seinem dorf
kein internet die eine ist rica
der andere nahm stieg die eine ist ihm
draußen unter anderem schlägt der eine
letztlich gerade sein wurdest du
entfernt diana lassen
schnell
überall nur leute die sich streiten und
schreiben
die spaltung wirklich sein
es gibt doch mehr als schwarz und weiß
und mehr als mann und frau
es gibt doch zwischen schwarz und weiß
so
das kann
[Musik]
deutsche zeichen als
der enzian
eine frisch verputzte brandschutz war
so ist das leben sonst fahren
so schön
hier
immerhin
70 prozent
durchgeführt
[Musik]
friedemann weise und sarah elena esser
unser von und für dieses jahr vielen
dank ans ganze team ihn fürs zu schauen
natürlich jetzt kommt der satirische
jahresrückblick der kollegen wiemers und
wir sehen uns wieder behaupte ich mal
ganz optimistisch am 28 januar bis dahin
schöne weihnachten und tschüss
[Musik]
der himmel
sie schlagen
wie wär's mit
kaum ein erwachsener
klar august statt schwarz-rot-gold
hier
st
[Musik]
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
los
los du scheiße fährt